Oh
right off the bat one of the things I
think that gamers are going to notice is
the huge improvement to the weapons that
sound goes through your body don't just
go and record a weapon you try to
recreate that feeling make it really
feel like you're really there a huge
part of audio for advanced warfare was
building intelligence into our systems
not to just play back cool sounds but to
monitor the outside world the cool thing
about that is not only as it sound more
realistic but you virtually never hear
the same impact or explosion twice
it's a futuristic setting but we want to
be believable we would always start with
something grounded and add new sounds
that we created ourselves mix it in
layer things so that you come up with
something truly unique a lot of times we
really focus in on one aspect the
vehicles the impact system dynamic range
or the mixing gradually these things
start to come together and when you're
done you see all these different audio
systems all working together and it
sounds like a movie but it's not a movie
it's happening right there
a pre-order now and supercharge your
loadout with the advanced arsenal